>> Laura: WE RECENTLY
WITNESSED THAT WEIRD SPECTACLE
OF ALLEY THEY'LL SEE READING
SCRIPTURE TO ATTACK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
THEN JEFF SESSIONS QUOTING THE
DEBATE.
LET'S DISCUSS THAT NOW WITH A
PAIR OF VERY DISTINGUISHED
RELIGIOUS LEADERS AND I'M
DELIGHTED THEY ARE BOTH WITH US.
COUNCIL AND DR. ENGEL.
DR. ENGEL, LET'S START WITH YOU.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY, I THINK A
SUPPORTER OF THE PRESIDENT BUT
YOU DISAGREE WITH HIS POLICY
THAT IT INITIALLY, AT LEAST,
SEPARATED FAMILIES, CHILD IN ONE
AREA, PARENTS MORE AND A FORMAL
AND HE IS TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING HE WANTS TO UPHOLD THE LAW
OF THE LAND, NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT.
I THINK THE ISSUE THERE WAS TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION WHICH HE
WANTS TO DO AS IT RELATES TO
BORDERS.
AND YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
PROTECTION, AND HOW DO YOU BRING
THE HUMAN ELEMENT INTO THIS
SITUATION, SO YOU CAN PROVIDE
HUMAN DIGNITY AND RESPECT AND
OUR PRESIDENT WILL STEP UP, IN A
OUR LEADERS WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING AND PROVIDE THAT
PROTECTIVE AND COMPASSIONATE
PIECES TO THIS LEGISLATION.
>> Laura: PASTOR SCOTT, THIS
IS BISHOP MICHAEL CURRY WHO IS
JUST SLAMMING JEFF SESSIONS OR
INVOKING THE BIBLE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> TO OUR CHRISTIANS TO QUOTE
ROMANS 13 OVER JESUS OF NAZARETH
AS IF JESUS OF NAZARETH DOESN'T
EXIST, THAT IS HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC.
IT'S FLAT OUT HIGHLY UNBIBLICAL,
UNCHRISTIAN AND UN-AMERICAN.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
AND I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY
ESPECIALLY IF YOU ARE A BIBLE
BELIEVER.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL TO REFER TO
SCRIPTURE AS A BASIS TO VALIDATE
ANY ACTIONS THAT YOU ENGAGE IN.
ONCE AGAIN, IF YOU ARE A BIBLE
BELIEVER, WE OFTENTIMES USE
SCRIPTURE TO VALIDATE ACTIONS OR
ACTIVITIES THAT WE ENGAGE IN.
SCRIPTURE, BECAUSE THAT
OBEY THE CIVIL AUTHORITIES.
JESUS NOR THE APOSTLE PAUL
ENDORSED SEDITION OR REBELLION
OR A VIOLENT UPRISING AGAINST
ROME AND USING THAT SCRIPTURE,
NOT THE WAY.
OBEY THE LAWS OF THE LAND SO
THEY DON'T HAVE A REASON TO
ACCUSE US OF ANY WRONGDOING.
OBEY THE LAWS OF THE LAND AND
PUT OTHER MATTERS INTO THE HANDS
WELCOME A STRANGER AND IT'S VERY
POWERFUL.
WELCOME INTO YOUR TABLE, INVITE
A STRANGER TO YOUR HOME FOR
WALL, REALLY NICE WALL.
BUT THAT MEANS ANYONE WHO STEPS
FOOT OVER THE BORDER HAS TO BE
PROCESSED INTO THE COUNTRY AND
RELEASED.
HOW IS THAT WELCOMING THE
THAT DOES NOT MEAN TO BE DEVOID
OF ALL LAWS OF THE LAND TO COME
UP DOES IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND I GO BACK TO THAT PASSAGE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL REFERRED TO
IN ROMANS 13 TALKING ABOUT, OBEY
THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE CONTEXT
OF GOD'S LAW, GOD'S LAW ALWAYS
FOR PROTECTION, ALWAYS FOR PEACE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE FACING WITH
IMMIGRATION REFORM, ALL THE
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN OVER THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS, YOU HAVE TO HAVE A COME
LOOK AT THE ISSUES OF
COLLABORATING ON PROVIDING
SECURITY AT THE WALL.
FAMILIES.
>> WE ALL DO WHAT WE CAN TO
DONATE TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT
CENTRAL AMERICA, SOUTH AMERICA,
AFRICA AND AROUND THE WORLD,
THAT'S WHERE WE AS INDIVIDUALS
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE THROUGH
OUR FAITH, OUR CHURCHES AND
ORGANIZATIONS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN WE COMPLETELY
HAVE TO SMASH OUR OWN RULE OF
LAW.
IF YOU HAVE A REALLY SAD LIFE
AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S HORRIBLE,
YOU COME IN.
AND I WANT TO GET PASTOR SCOTT
KNOWN AS FATHER JAMES MARTIN.
HE'S NOT A BIG FAN OF TRUNK TO
PUT IT LIGHTLY.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> NO ONE WANTS TO BE A REFUGEE
THEY HAVE LOTS OF GUTS TO DO IT
AND IT'S UP TO US TO WELCOME
OF THESE CHRISTIANS WHO SAY THEY
READ THE BIBLE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT BIBLE THEY ARE READING
BECAUSE THE BIBLE I READ HAS
JESUS REACHING OUT TO THOSE ON
THE MARGINS, INCLUDING AND MOST
ESPECIALLY, MIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES.
>> Laura: PASTOR SCOTT, A LOT
OF AMERICANS FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
ON THE MARGINS.
LIKE TWO BLOCKS FROM WHERE WE
>> THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
MIGRANTS, REFUGEES AND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
CRIME WHEN THEY ENDEAVOR TO
SNEAK INTO THIS COUNTRY.
THERE IS A ZERO-TOLERANCE POLICY
BUT THEY TRY TO SNEAK IN
ANYWAYS.
NOW ANYONE, AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
IF THEY DON'T LIKE YOU ARE
ENGAGED IN THE COMMISSION OF A
CRIME AND YOU ARE CAUGHT,
APPREHENDED, AND YOU HAVE A
CHILD IN YOUR CUSTODY, THAT
CHILD WILL BE REMOVED FROM YOUR
CUSTODY AND BE PLACED INTO CHILD
SERVICES UNTIL SOMEONE EITHER
TAKING ANY CULPABILITY FROM THE
CRIME BEING COMMITTED AWAY FROM
THE PARENTS AND MAKE IT JUST
GRABBING KIDS AND PUTTING THEM
INTO CONCENTRATION CAMPS,
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE CASE AT
ALL.
THERE IS A CRIME BEING COMMITTED
AND THE CHILDREN ARE IN THE
CUSTODY.
>> Laura: AND ITS
DONALD TRUMP'S FAULT.